In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for July 2, on which we commemorate the Holy Hierarch,
John of Shanghai and San Francisco, the Wonderworker, the memory of St. John Maximovich, Archbishop
of Shanghai, Brussels, and then San Francisco.
Born in 1896 in the village of Adamovka in the province of Karkov, the blessed Hierarch
John belonged to the noble Maximovich family.
Given the name Michael at Holy Baptism, he received his secondary education at the military
school in Boltava and then studied law at Karkov University.
During the civil war that followed the revolution in 1921, his family fled to Belgrade, where
he completed his theological studies.
In 1926 he was concerted monk by Metropolitan Antony Karpowitsky, one of the most brilliant
Russian hierarchs to escape the terrors of the revolution.
Receiving the name of his Kinsman John of Tobolsk, he was soon appointed tutor and professor
in the Serbian seminary in Bitalia, where he greatly influenced the students with his
ascetic life and his paternal care.
Having done the rounds of the dormitories, he would spend the night in prayer, giving
only an hour or two to sleep, either seated or prostrate before the icons.
He later admitted that from his monastic profession onwards he never laid down to sleep.
He ate only once a day, a little before midnight, and during the great fast he took only
altar bread, fasting completely the first and last weeks.
He was consecrated bishop in 1934, despite his reservations, and was sent to Shanghai where
he worked unstintingly for the support and comfort of the many Russian refugees.
He began by bringing together the orthodox of various nationalities who had been divided
by jurisdictional disputes, and organized help for the poorest.
He constantly roamed the streets to gather sick children and orphans, both Russian and Chinese.
The orphanage, which he founded and placed under the protection of St. Tikhon of Sedansk, began
with eight children and had given shelter to 3,500 when the coming of the communists forced
the community to flee, first to the Philippines, and then to the USA.
Despite his pastoral responsibilities, St. John followed and even increased his asceticism
and he celebrated the divine liturgy every day.
Inflicted with ulcerated legs, he refused surgery.
When at last he gave in to his parishioners' urging, he was in church on the very evening
of the operation, celebrating the vigil of the exaltation of the Holy Cross.
Being content with the poorest clothing, he only wore thin sandals, which he often gave
away to a poor man and always celebrated barefoot to the great displeasure of some people.
Having thus Godward through asceses like the fathers of old, he received from God the
gift of insight, which he used with discernment for the salvation and edification of souls.
He spent most of his time visiting the sick, taking them holy communion and the comfort of
God's presence, not turning his back on prisoners or the mentally sick who received him calmly
and with joy, listening attentively to his sermons.
During the Japanese occupation, when the Russian community in Shanghai was constantly under threat,
the courageous bishop in danger of his life took on the guidance and the continued visiting
of his flock, even in the depths of night and in the most dangerous districts.
With the arrival of the communists in 1949, the Russian refugees of Shanghai, 5,000 of
them, were evacuated to a typhoon-prone island in the Philippines, but protected by the prayers
of their pastor, the refugee camp was spared during the 27 months of their stay.
Shortly after most of the refugees had left, a terrible typhoon completely destroyed the
camp.
Having succeeded in getting emigration papers to the USA for his flock, the indefatigable
pastor was appointed Archbishop of the Russian Church outside Russia for Western Europe
in 1951.
Having his seat at first in Paris, he then lived in Brussels.
Far from confining himself to the needs of the Russian emigres, he took a lively interest
in the restoration of orthodoxy in the West and showed great devotion to the saints of
the West before the schism, working to restore their liturgical commemoration.
In Europe, as in China and later in the USA, the blessed man continued to regulate his conduct
entirely by the Divine Law with no regard for social conventions, which drew criticism
from some, but from others admiration as a fool for Christ of our times.
One day, a Catholic priest wanting to assure his congregation that holiness was not a thing
of the past, cried out in his sermon, see, a saint is walking the streets of Paris today,
John the Barefoot.
In 1963, he was sent urgently to San Francisco to restore peace to the Russian community there,
which was divided over the building of the cathedral.
Uncomplaningly bearing calumny, without ever judging others or losing his inner peace,
he was even prepared to appear contrary to the Holy Canons before a civil court to answer
accusations of misuse of funds.
He was indeed strict where the morals of his parishioners and the preservation of ecclesiastical
tradition were concerned, but he spread an abundance of divine love on those who gathered
round him, always showing a genial care for children.
Having long foretold the day of his death, he fell asleep in peace on the 19th of June,
the 2nd of July in the Civil Calendar in 1966 in Seattle.
His obsequies in the Cathedral in San Francisco were a triumph of reconciled orthodoxy, among
the thousands of the faithful who for six days came to venerate his remains.
There were many who noted that they showed no sign of corruption and gave off a sweet
fragrance.
Ever since then, the blessed man has testified many times to his heavenly assistance for
the faithful who call upon it.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.